c'era un sito quando ero piccolo quindi
ieri che mi piaceva visitare un sacco e
no non è quello che pensate
quello era un altro sito c'è un sito che
si chiamava enigmi puntonet dove
praticamente quando risolvervi un enigma
potevi passare alla pagina successiva
volevo provare visto che ormai sono
cresciuto sono diventato grande per
vedere se faccio meglio di quando ero
piccolo quindi eni quinto nei tre
incontri è la madonna in molti hanno
provato a raggiungere la fine 168 sono
riusciti a risolvere l'enigma in quanti
ci hanno provato è vecchissima è sta
roba c'è proprio vecchia dc a più di
dieci anni
obiettivo del gioco con ritrova la
parola per accedere all enigma
successiva per superare dovrei in
sostituire l'url l'indirizzo della
pagina con la parola trovata risolvendo
l'enigma la parola e gatto allora
bisogna scrivere enigmi e gatto punto
html con divertimento inizia vai
lasciate ogni speranza o voi che entrate
che simpatici let's go livello superato
che questo era facile grazie a dio
clicca qui però c'era persino livello
bene livello 2 punto htm basta scrivere
livello treno quello perfetto era
difficile questa a perché nell indirizzo
html della pagina ci sono degli indizi
poco robe criptiche
scrivi nella bara di nizza immagina
conto che deve morire qua ci siamo
e ancora adesso ne aggregata vai livello
superato è quarto livello
e che ne so ma posso anche salvare la
luminosità e contrasto punto jpeg
quindi devo lavorare sulle editor delle
immagini per trovargli indizi
fermi tutti luminosità e contrasto dei
colori non esita contrasto con tassi
vedo un caz paga so io scemo o bingo
punto htm michia risorse tito sherlock
per un attimo è stato bellissimo figo
come ho fatto la piccolo che non sapeva
usa realisti programmi aveva chiesto
aiuto a più di fi bingo hdm perfetto
toni f informazioni punto ht quindi dove
delle informazioni impediamo alcune
immagini nascondono informazioni
presenti al loro interno se dopo che le
insalate sotto pc come già fatto preso
di mira le leggi nelle proprietà
cliccandoci addirittura di proprietà
delle immagini in proprietà info punto
jpeg dove dovrei trovare l'indizio
vanitoso punto htm
grazie vanitoso dovrebbe essere
l'orsacchiotto mica perché non conosce
l'età di pg lega vanitoso let's go
british ha comunque so brower scimmie
tra il dietro qualche indizio vedi le
scimmie che giocano
no no non le vedo le scimmie che giocano
ragazzo scemo io ragazza l'ho io
veramente stupido ma vi giuro non sto
vedendo nessuna scimmia che gioca co sto
contorcendo le immagini per trovare gli
indizi c'è proprio veramente neanche
sherlock le regole le scimmie che
giocano dai veti stessi nier ma devono
trovarlo in mezzo qualcosa o se starò
bastasse scimmie ma scrive sommato di
così i pixel se non ha veramente senso
di esistere
consorella una scimmia non capitolo c'è
una cosa che non capisco cosa è prove
[Musica]
nexon le nuvole
eccola scusate dei problemi non vedo
scimmie furto furto furto che cazzo
c'entra alle scimmie vale qua quali
scimmie oddio che è successo qua c'è
un'immagine di minchia rega aiuto
accidenti c'è un errore come vendita il
codice la foto di internet explor
internet explore capo vecchio sto gioco
e sto cercando di caricare e errore
punto bmp ma la foto corretta errore
punto jpeg prova a inserire jpeg sulla
barra indirizzi per mandarmi un sms
ma chi li manda gli sms a cosa servono
credo che su questo telefono non
funzionasse whatsapp ai tempi però non
sarà un sicuro
salviamo che mica scritto qualcosa nelle
proprietà dell'immagine si è co 2 2 3 3
quad est e non leggo una sega 23 30 ho
capito devo schiacciare i tassi mi
chiedo perché tasti schiaccio qua non
spieghi tu per creare le sms ma di mente
che pazzi maniaci allora telefono
vecchio un po meno ok questo che va bene
che se c'è una faccia bruttissima il suo
telefono mamma mia ok alle 22 era 22 15
cesa cesaris a cesareo cesareo punto htm
che è un parto un parto suo livello
barton cesare che però nera cesareo e
parto
vai perfetto ma poi perché non facendo
manderà avanti non so se era arrivato
quando ero piccolo non me lo ricordavo
questo tasselli la madonna può
interagire fighissimo fare aiuto fatemi
ispezionare che non vedo non vedo
inserisci 4 un ppe nelle fessure nessuna
delle quattro devi incrociarsi con le
altre ne verticalmente e orizzontalmente
integralmente così otterrà una soluzione
chiarissimo professor layton si deve
spostare rega perfetto subito messo un
secolo ottavo nano ottavo nano punto htm
l'indizio quindi nota lavorano perché in
tutti i miei video tutti anche in quelli
dove non dovrebbe esserci c'è pietro con
tutti non ha la fissa cucciolo punto
jpeg
vabbè fammi capire commenti a va bene in
che senso ha ok infezione e gli altri
fratelli e saranno morti che ti devo
dire poi che c'era con nani sto sito non
capisco queste cucciolo egli ha dovuto
mettere i nomi degli altri mammolo
ha forse devo usare jpeg spetterà a
funziona mi chiede culo mammolo pisolo
finché americano neanche lo salva miti
sette nani sul computer ma ti pare animi
che funziona ti prego potrei troppo
ridere dove ci ho provato salvatico 1 su
sono uno più fatto dell'altro tra
l'altro mammolo che ci hanno i commenti
lati quindi devo ricordarmi tutte le
lettere è uscito fuori questo però non
credo abbia un senso di esistere quindi
devo riordinare se lettere cascata
cascata cascata fa chi è a rega fa chi è
un fenomeno famiglia 35 per due per tre
15 ai 18 45 x 2 fa8 io ti maledica male
no 77 per 321 quindi che ci faccio
questo 21 ma che si chiama inc punto
jpeg boing boing anche se non ha senso
e 3,5 x 2 15 e 18 quanto fa pirla capito
che doveva suo conto nas e 21 fa 21 boy
21 boeing 3000c che per due prevendite
fa 21 by 21 boeing central boeing
l'aereo immaginano esiste un boeing 21
se boeing porca eva boing triplo 7 non è
possibile abusatori serio voi triplo 7 a
7 14 21 ma va a cagare
grazie toni f grazie grazie alla talpa
iodice qatar polo e stupida bufo bufo
ragazzi per adesso direi che col triplo
7 fosse conclude quasi del traverso non
contento così non vicolo sarà arrivato
quando non penso proprio cioè quando il
piccolo giallo arriva a malapena
riusciva a per la prima pagina quindi va
bene è stato bello fare un tuffo nel
passato ricordandomi di essere un po
share lo un po scemo ma anche un
processo come se i ragazzi si vede
piaciuto quel momento mi piace anche
vari social compito notizia
[Musica]